all right 6 25 in your monday morning
what's driving you crazy how about the
last chance for you to weigh in
on the fix up to the longest bridge in
southern nevada
now you might not think of this as a
bridge however the stretch of the 95 515
heading east out of the spaghetti bowl
is indeed a bridge that is technically
known as a
viaduct that's defined as a bridge for
carrying a road over a valley consisting
of a number of short spans
well the nevada department of
transportation had a virtual public
meeting open for a couple of weeks
it is scheduled to shut down tomorrow
construction right around the corner
southbound drivers you're going to get
an auxiliary lane
also the freeway bridges over eastern
and further south at di they are going
to be completely replaced
so when you go to i515.com you're
greeted
by a virtual receptionist you use the
arrow keys on your computer to scroll
around the
meeting room it is set up with giant
virtual screens you can click on for a
project overview
the various phases of the project and a
page to leave public comment
we've got that link on our website
8newsnow.com buckle up drive carefully
and please put down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8
8 news now dot com